i'd like to take a minute to talk about
martial arts systems and what they are
there's a lot of con confusion about
what martial arts systems are and that
confusion
makes it very difficult for people to
actually study the martial arts so
you have to understand that a system is
a framework that's designed to help you
look at and understand an aspect
of conflict
so uh
when you're looking at a system its job
is basically to teach you about aspects
of conflict certain aspects of conflict
and depending on what the system is uh
is is what aspects it will teach right
so for example western boxing will teach
you
methods for defending against and
attacking
unarmed in a striking context with the
upper body only right or with the hands
only specifically
a kickboxing system will add to that and
teach you something about uh using your
legs and kicking and defending against
kicks um a grappling system will teach
you about methods to wrestle and
different grappling systems will teach
you different kinds of things and
different ways you might grapple
so the system's designed to illustrate
for you and give you a framework to work
with aspects of a part of fighting
and so that's all the system really is
it it's to help you get better and to
understand an aspect of fighting
but when people look at systems they
they think that the system
is the event right and so by by is the
event what i mean is either the system
is the fight right so like this system
is the way fighting is and that's not
true of any system
the only exception may be being a sports
system that teaches to the sport which
the sport is the method you're looking
at but outside of sport fighting
there is no system that can teach you
what is fighting because it's always
changing and adapting and evolving
depending on the situation right where
you're at who the people are uh what we
have available to us stuff like that so
it's always changing so no system can
really teach you what fighting is
or people think that a martial arts
system is the event because they think
somehow that
the martial art is a person or something
or that if you if you train enough in
the martial art you 100 can represent
what that system is and and that's not
true either right so
systems can only give you ideas and help
you look at uh an aspect of of the
conflict and they can't they aren't the
conflict themselves and they can't stand
up for themselves right so you know if
you wanted to compare uh western
wrestling in western boxing and you put
them together there's going to be
strengths and weaknesses of the two
people there's always the medium of the
person that the system has to go through
so you really can never compare uh
western boxing and western wrestling
they they can't they can't compare them
directly because there's the medium of a
person and the media the person is the
important thing right the the system is
designed to teach you something the
person who's studying it something but
the important thing is to understand the
system is not the event the system is
not the person who does the fighting and
it is not the fight it's just a
framework that you can work with and
help you to understand a part of a fight
so
so what is the system and what does the
system do basically martial arts systems
they take a an aspect of fighting and
they give you
something to work with in in that aspect
um and it's really hard the system
becomes really
complicated and a lot becomes involved
the more things we add to the system so
it's almost impossible it probably is
completely impossible to have an
absolutely complete martial arts system
that looks at all aspects of conflict
next conflict's a huge huge category um
and even if you get into physical
conflict only you want to look at
physical conflict it's also a huge
subject matter right
um it's huge because not only do you
have to understand um all the unarmed
methods of doing things right so like
all the ways to use your body and that
would be huge that would be a gigantic
system in and of itself like all the
ways to punch and kick and strike and
things will include biting and clawing
and all the things that might be useful
to fighting would have to be in in that
system then we have to add all the
aspects of weapon training right and so
you could have basic handheld weapons
and that would be in and of itself a
huge category you know everything doing
with uh clubs and everything to do with
blades and
projectile weaponry all these things
that would all have to be included and
that would be that would be a big system
and then you would also have to start to
include other things that we use in
conflict right so people use helicopters
in conflict people use horses and
conflict we use all kinds of things and
and saying horses that there's another
aspect we'd have to include in that
which is you know historical elements um
so do you want to look at things from
the past and things from the modern day
so a complete martial arts system would
would probably be impossible because it
would involve too much
so what we do really simply is we break
down aspects of fighting and we put them
in systems and people who are interested
in setting the different aspects can
just go to the other smaller systems and
study what that's about right the
military has really nice ways of looking
at this you know if you you look at what
someone does in the military you know
maybe they studied uh in an escape and
evasion school and then they studied in
a sniper school and they took martial
art hand-to-hand combatives you know you
can see that they picked out all these
things for what they want to do or you
know communications i mean that's an
aspect of conflict um lots of different
parts
um that they can pick and choose to
comprise what they want to do so you
study the system not to become the
ultimate complete warrior in the world
but instead to
improve yourself in those different
aspects of of what the martial arts are
right so the different aspects the first
part is the context for the system so
that's the dominating factor of the
system the context is what are we going
to do with this system so it could be um
knife fighting for example we could
knife fighting could be our system
that's our context we're only going to
look at knife fighting and it does need
to be
a little more simplified most likely to
make a good system uh because i mean you
could just have the whole world of knife
fighting but that includes a lot of
things like different size knives
all kinds of stuff has to be involved in
that so we'll say we're going to look at
a system for knife fighting that is uh
armed versus unarmed i'm always going to
be armed right so we're looking at a
system where i'm always going to have a
knife
and other people aren't going to have a
knife and i'm fighting them and of
course that could be one-on-one or
multiple attackers i could be looking at
all kinds of aspects it could be in the
dark it could be you know in crazy
environments you know we could be in the
water or whatever who knows why i want
my system but that's the first part is
the context right so if we have a knife
fighting
and each context is going to be specific
to the martial arts system right so
there's rifle context there's helicopter
context there's unarmed context there's
kicking contests and wrestling contexts
all kinds of contexts but that's the
first part of our system the first part
we need is what is our context what is
the system to do
the next is theory of use so theory of
use is what we're going to do within
that context right so for example if
we're looking at our knife system i
could have a defensive theory of use
which maybe i uh always keep the knife
in the reverse grip and i keep it in the
back hand i use my my front hand here to
push people away from me and when they
get close i can use my knife
in a powerful hammer motion uh to attack
them right so that would be a defensive
theory for our knife fighting system i
could have an offensive theory right
whereas like i'm going to keep my knife
in the foregrip and the forehand so that
way anyone comes at me i'm going to
attack them and i'm going to be marching
towards people and i'm not going to be
in a defensive posture at all i'm going
to be attacking
so there's lots of lots of theories of
use i could have so our first part is
context how are we what's a system for
the second part is how are we going to
use the system within that context so
what's our our outlook on
um
on the the context itself um and then
the next and this is really the last
step of all um
systems is how are we going to teach
those things to people right so how are
we going to transmit the knowledge so
first step is context second steps
theory of use third step is transmission
so how are we going to transmit what we
know about the about this this idea of
this this context to other people so
um and that would be stuff like uh
physical exercise we're going to do the
kind of conditioning people have to be
in right you have to be in extremely
good shape do you have to have good
cardio do you have to have really strong
biceps do you have to you know what are
what are the physical requirements for
that system so that's going to be in it
the exercises we need to do
how we actually get the ideas across
right so in a lot of traditional
japanese martial arts for example um
static kata is the way it's taught so
we're gonna this form we're gonna
memorize this form and by memorizing
this form we're gonna learn the things
that go into this right we're gonna
understand the theory of use and how we
use the weapon and all the little
technical details through kata
a modern idea that's really appearing a
lot now is this idea of live training so
we're just going to put you in that
context sport martial arts do this a lot
you know i'm just going to put you
inside that context and you're going to
scramble around and see what happens and
we'll give you some ideas here and there
from people who have been there
themselves and that's it that's what
we're going to do so there's lots of
ways we can transmit
the things we know about it so there's
three parts to a system the first part
of the context of the system the second
part is the theory of use within that
context and the third part is
transmission of the information
within that context so basically i want
to make this video
so we could start to talk about what
martial arts systems really are as
opposed to having this
kind of crazy idea the martial arts
system itself is some kind of magical
thing it's either going to make you an
ultimate invincible warrior or that it
uh can get up and fight on its own or
that once you know it you're
undefeatable or who knows you have lots
of crazy ideas about what systems are
but this the truth is the system's
really nice thing to to look at to help
you understand an aspect of conflict and
as martial artists that's what we study
we study conflicts so uh understanding
different systems and how they work and
how you wanna to use them and implement
them is very important you know if uh if
you're looking at yourself in some
situation you know so you know you
regularly get beat up by the
neighborhood kids and how are you going
to stop that um
well they usually um they punch me so
well first thing i guess i need to do is
to learn how to defend myself against
punches so oh i should look at a system
that talks about defending against
punches right so western boxing probably
a great system to study to learn how to
defend against those punches and then
you keep getting in a fight with those
kids and they don't hurt you as much
anymore but you really can't do anything
to stop them so it's like well then how
can i stop things like and you start
weighing your options maybe i need to
learn a lot about striking maybe i need
to learn how to grapple and take one of
them down
so you know
you study the system to help you
understand different aspects of conflict
and conflicts loaded with lots of
different aspects right and i really
basically just touched on the the
physical aspects there's also
non-physical aspects you know there's
verbal confrontation there's mental
ideas about what's happening as lots of
things can happen
inside of conflict
and so you should never look to one
system to answer everything and you
should never um you know demonize a
system for not doing what you wanted it
to do
you should try and understand the system
for what it's designed to do and and
look at it that way so this is a little
bit about systems i hope it helps some
of you get a better idea of what's going
on with systems in the martial arts i'm
chris hein thanks a lot